hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the origami ninja Sai
over the years I've gotten many requests
to do an origami sword so I craved my
very own just like the ones that Rafael
uses in Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles as
someone commented so after posting a
poll on my last video where over 75% of
people voted for it and a picture on my
community tab reading all of the
comments from everybody saying they
wanted to see it today I'll show you how
you can turn your very own paper into
this epic ninja side that you can even
spin around your finger I am using
printer paper for this tutorial so I can
draw on the paper easily but I think it
looks a lot cooler with origami paper
and it even color changes as you can see
I even made this super sized one with
gold foil paper since some folds of the
Ninja side can be a little bit trickier
than some of my easier models I do
recommend you try some of my more
challenging tutorials like the Rose Swan
or the magic bulb before attempting it
even so I will be going through it in
detail to make it as easy as I can so
just grab your paper and will turn it
into your very own ninja side to make
your printer paper into a square take
the top edge and the corner and align it
with the left side and tear or cut the
excess paper off if you're using two
colored origami paper start with the
white side face up and make that same
diagonal fold since we have a crease
going this way in the paper we're going
to make one this way by taking the upper
left corner and folding it down to the
bottom right corner line up the edges as
neatly as you can and then make a nice
sharp crease on the upper left and just
run your fingernail against it to make
sure it's nice and sharp when you open
up the paper you'll see we now have an X
in it we're just going to turn it like
this so that it looks like a diamond and
we're going to take these outside
corners and fold them directly into the
middle so just line it up as neat as you
can and just make a crease to get under
here just kind of run your finger like
that that way it's nice and sharp on top
where the sword tips going to be do the
same with the other one so fold the left
edge directly into the middle and give
it a crease and now we have what's
called the kite base now we can take
these same edges in the middle and fold
them directly to the outside on both
sides just take it
round it off a little like this line it
up with the outer edge here make a
crease just run your finger under here
to kind of get it all the way to the top
like that give it a good crease it's
okay if it doesn't line up all the way
on top we can correct that later repeat
the same on the left side by folding the
inner edge to the outside creasing it so
that it looks something like this
now we could flip the whole thing over
and we're going to take these outside
edges and fold it directly on to this
mid line so just take the whole thing
here round it off and line it up with
the middle so fold the right edge
directly into the middle round it off
and crease it to the top doing the same
on the left side be sure to flatten
everything out once you're done you
should have something that looks like
this with two little top flaps and two
bottom flaps if you're using origami
paper it'll look something like this
we're going to take these two edges and
we're just going to open them up like
this and when you do that you'll see
that we have these creases that go from
the corner here to the center and they
converge on this little point that I've
drawn we're going to take the bottom and
we're going to fold it up at this point
so what you do just press here and pinch
it right at that point like that and
then lift the bottom to the top making
sure that this point stays right in the
middle of the paper like that then you
could just pinch it on the bottom here
set it down and then you can crease on
the bottom by holding here in the middle
and creasing across and just flatten
everything out when you open it up
you'll see that we made a crease at this
point all the way across just leave it
like that you'll also see that we have
these creases that go from here to the
corner again I'm just gonna draw on
those so you could see them easier now
we're going to take this top part that
we just folded up and round it off and
fold it down so that this edge right
here lies directly on that line that I
drew on both sides just like this round
the paper off and pull the tip down
until this edge is on that line then you
can just crease along the top of the
paper just like this then you could line
the right side edge up with that same
line and crease everything on top making
sure it is nice and flat once your paper
looks like this then we can move on pull
the paper open and you'll see we just
made a mountain fold from this corner to
this corner and a valley-fold at the
point that I marked where the creases
meet in the middle the origami paper
will look something like this
just pull the paper open and turn it to
the back and we're going to fold these
two bottom layer edges directly into the
center just like before fold the edge
and round it off and crease it directly
into the middle trying to get all the
way up to the top to make a sharp point
repeat it on the left side by folding
the left edge into the middle also now
the back of your paper should look just
like this now turn the paper back over
to the front and we could refold on that
Valley fold upwards flatten it out and
then we could once again
refold downwards on that mountain fold
just flatten the paper out and your
paper should look something like this
now now we could take the paper and flip
it over completely and we're going to
take these two edges here and fold them
up so that they meet this edge right
here pull it up and just line it with
the top and give it a crease as you'll
see this edge right here should kind of
meet up with this crease that's already
in the paper do the same on the left
side fold it up and give it a good
crease unfold those edges we just fold
it in and flip the model over again now
we're going to fold this edge into the
center on its existing crease and when
we do that you'll see this part of it
right here will line up with the top and
get tucked into the center just flatten
everything out once it's tucked in do
the same on the left side by folding the
edge in pressing right in here and
making sure the edge aligns with the top
and flatten everything out once you've
finished it you'll have something that
looks just like this and this is what I
call the sword base at this point your
sword base should look like this
and if you used origami paper you'll see
the blade will be in white with the
cross guard and the hilt or handle being
colored so just flip the base upside
down so you're looking at the back of it
and we're folding this edge up so
that aligns with this edge here of the
top of the cross guard just take the
bottom edge here and round it up
so that it lines up with the top here
and just give it a good push all the way
across like that it will be pretty thick
but once you're done it'll look
something like this now we're going to
take these outer edges here and fold
them into the middle by just pressing
here and folding it in like this the
reason that we're pressing like this is
because we don't want to pull too much
on this edge here fold it in like this
all the way to the bottom we're going to
take this edge right here and we're
going to press them together like this
and then we're going to flatten it out
do the same on the left side so fold the
left edge into the center now while
pressing down work your way all the way
down and when you get here
tug on that little corner press the
edges together push it in and flatten it
out it should look like this now now
we're going to take this edge here and
we're going to fold it up to the top of
the cross guard starting from the
outside and working our way in fold it
up so that it lines up with the top edge
and just work your way in like this when
you get here you'll notice that there's
a little bit of excess and it won't go
flat so what you're going to do is just
take your finger and push in here like
that and then you could flatten it out
do the same on the left side start on
the outside and fold it up work your way
in and when you get here just tuck it
underneath and flatten it out now your
paper will look something like this
now we're going to work on the handle or
hilt and to do that just lift this up
like this and you'll see we have an edge
here we're going to lift it up by
putting our finger underneath it and
squeezing it to the back of the paper
like this now fold this edge in about
1/4 of an inch
we're not folding it all the way to the
center so just fold it in and just
crease it all the way down just like
this now just push it here and then you
could press everything down firmly like
this and flatten it out do the same
thing on the left by lifting the edge up
and squeezing it to the underside
folding the edge in and creasing it all
the way down pressing here with your
fingers and flatten everything out this
next part for shaping the cross guard
here can be pretty tricky there is an
easier way so if you have trouble with
it I'll put a subtitle in the video down
here you can go to where I'll show you
the quick and easy version which comes
out looking like this to shape the cross
guard like this however which I think
looks a little better we're going to
first unfold the edges we just fold it
in if you're going to use the easier way
don't unfold the edges so to shape the
cross guard I'm just going to use the
origami paper so you could see what
happens with the colors I'm just going
to unfold these edges that we just fold
it in for the hilt and then flatten it
back out and flip it over now here we
have these two edges on the bottom we're
just going to fold this edge to the
outside by lifting up this corner and
folding this edge to the outside like
this and making a crease do the same on
the left side
then you could unfold it we're just
going to lift up this edge like this and
we're going to press this edge here so
that it lines up with the one underneath
so just press it like this all the way
up to this little crease here and push
on this crease just continue pushing the
edge underneath there tucking it in give
it a little pinch and then flatten it
down like that do the same on the left
side lift the edge up align this edge
with the one underneath give it a
squeeze and flatten it out now we're
going to flip it over and we're going to
fold these edges back in lift this
corner up again and fold this edge into
the center on the existing crease when
you do that you'll see this little tent
area will kind of pull along so just
hold it here and push your finger into
this tent area just like this and
flatten it out then you could just push
down on the back and do the same on the
left side so just lift up this corner
and fold the edge in and when you do
you'll have that tent that you're just
going to push your finger in flatten it
out like this then you could just put
the sword down on the table and just
crease it well throughout so it should
look just like this now to do the
simpler version just take the sword like
this and we're just going to crease
upwards on this edge by just folding the
excess up like this and the same on the
other side
then you could flip it over and we're
just going to fold these edges to the
outside like this and like this
now you could follow along with the rest
of the tutorial on how to finish it to
finish the ninja Sai if you look on the
back here you'll see there's a little
bit of excess that's hanging over
we just need to fold this up like this
and give it a crease do the same with
the other side then you can unfold it
and tuck it underneath here
just give it a crease do the same with
this side now you can flip it over now
we can just fold this edge up so it's
facing directly upwards like that and
give it a crease here on the right side
unfold it and then fold it back the
other way on the same crease give it a
nice sharp crease on the outside just
like this and flatten it out put your
finger in here and pinch it right here
lift up this edge on those two creases
that we just made then you could pinch
these two corners together here then we
can also press the edges together just
like this like you would for a bird head
then just do the same thing on the other
side fold it up give it a sharp crease
fold it back on the same crease that we
just made slide your finger in and fold
it up on those two creases pinch the two
corners together and squeeze the edges
flatten everything out and adjust it if
necessary
so now you've completed the ninja Sai
and I'll show you how you can spin it to
spin it you can try to put your finger
in here and do it without any adjustment
but what I like to do is to just take
this edge fold it down like this and
then you can open up these two edges
push down like this and do an outside
reverse fold then you can put your
finger in here and your middle finger is
going to push on the hilt like that
I hope you guys like the tutorial for
the ninja Sai if you did be sure to give
it a thumbs up down below and leave me a
comment let me know what you thought of
it was easy for you to make was a
difficult was challenging it was
definitely a challenging tutorial for me
to make as you can see but I hope you
guys weren't able to make it leave me a
comment down below let me know what
you'd like to see next and then just our
boomerang transforming boomerang that
would take a while for me to figure out
hope you guys are enjoying your summer
staying healthy and I'll see you soon